hello everyone and welcome to another
incredible game from Round 4 of this
year's stata steel Masters Edition it is
world number two dingler and also the
world Chase Championship Challenger uh
again not the world's Championship
Challenger as okay how do you call it if
he's playing against Nepal who is also a
World Series Championship Challenger so
they are both worlds Championship
Challengers like uh I guess uh he's
playing against pregnant and okay
there's a there's a bit of a difference
in raiding here as ding is the only uh
other uh 2800 player in the world other
than Magnus Carlson but both of them
have been having an excellent tournament
so far Prague with three draws I think
he drew against Arjun against Lebon and
against Vincent and being with two draws
and one when uh he defeated uh gookish I
believe in round one so let's see what
happened in this one it's uh quite a
game and uh well uh it uh it's really a
great opportunity for Prague black
pieces against the ding so let's see
what happens uh ding opens with Ponte E4
with E5 Knight to F3 Knight to C6 and
now Bishop the C4 going for the Italian
game uh Bishop to C5 and now ding just
castles not going for the absolute best
move but okay Knight to F6 with D3 D6 uh
and now Pawn to C3 we have A6 this is
all very standard stuff nothing new here
Rook to E1 we often say that Knight to
G4 is pointless you're just gonna defend
the pawn and kick away the knight uh
Bishop back to A7 and now uh Pawn to a
for Bishop to B4 still by far the my
most played move but uh dingoes for the
second most popular Ponte A4 we have
Castles by Prague H3 and now Bishop to
E6 so again all been seen before nothing
new here standard stuff of the Joker
piano captures captures bishopter that's
not a bishop Bishop to E3 and here
Bishop captures on E3 and this is where
the game uh takes an interesting turn
the position was reached uh even some 10
games in um top level games read your
disposition for example Maxima Shiela
grab defeated Demetria kovenko here with
Rook captures on E3 also Hans Neiman
tried real captors and E3 against
Fabiano caruana although he lost that
game but in all of the game's Rook
captures and E3 was played but here ding
plays F captures on E3 and it is now as
of move 12 that we have a completely new
game
so let's see how Prague adapts to this
new idea and is it a surprise for him he
plays Pawn to A5 as one always should
you are stopping B4 maybe you have some
ideas of Shifting The Rook over to the
to the B file but as you'll see in the
game that's not prog's main intent
Knight to D2 and he plays Queen to D7 so
now he connects the Rooks and the Rooks
can now be developed to d8 the E8 is
going to remain on f8 all depending on
what the ding plays with Queen to B3
going after the B7 pawn and now just
Pawn to B6 defending the the structure
Rook 8 to D1 and now King the h8
unpinning from this diagonal we have
Queen to B5 now uh saying that if you
move the Knight I'm I'm going to trade
queens and that's exactly what Prague
does he plays Knight to d8 and he
admites ding for an uh uh uh well just a
a beginning of an end game so Queen
characters Knight captures and now Pawn
to D4 so it's a bit of a different than
if Rook captured underneath three but I
don't think this the structures that
arise from from this are any surprised
at the Prague so Knight to F7 we have
King the F2 ding now wants to get his
King to the center of the board Knight
the G5 offering some trades here King E2
and Knight captures and F3 with Knight
captures and F3 and Knight to F6 so just
nicely trading down a lot of tension in
the center as you can see the position
is almost uh symmetrical uh you know if
if you consider the pawns uh but um uh
that means that there's not all that
much to do some Knights the D2 uh we
have King the G8 the king no longer
needs to stay in the in the corner of
the board Rook to F1 now we have Rook F
the E8 uh now Prague wants to play Rook
8 to d8 and have the other rook and E8
and then start opening up the middle of
the board as ding's king is uh well just
in the center of the board
uh so Rook to F3 and now Rook 8 to d8
and here ding plays G4 he wants to play
G5 and if Prague allows this could be
very nice for ding but Prague boss for
the instant Pawn to D5 and uh in the
interview after the game Prague said
that this might have been something that
being missed because there's just uh not
a good reply for white because what you
really don't want to do with the white
pieces is just allow black to trade on
everything uh and then black is just
equal or better and I mean that's uh
they played The Joker piano that's just
no way to live with with white so
problem is let's say d captures an E5
here okay look at those triple pawns
Knight at the D7 can be played also
something that program mentioned that
maybe ding didn't take into
consideration now Knight captures an E5
is coming will be attacking the Rooks
are gonna have to move the Rook Knight
captures on E5 and black is uh well uh
just has a spectacular position here on
the other hand after this D5 move if you
go for E Captain D5 also just e
characters on D5 and now if Rook the F5
putting pressure on the E Pawn you can
just play e captures on D4 C captures on
D4 and now Pawn to C5 putting pressure
on the D4 pawn and the white king is
still a little bit vulnerable in the
center so ding doesn't like either idea
he just moves The Rook back Rook F to F1
and now e captures on D4 C characters
and D captures an E4 temporarily winning
a pawn uh but only temporarily Pawn to
G5 ding finally gets this move in
Knights to D5 and not Knight captures on
e4 but Prague continues uh busting
through the center just Pawn to E5 and
okay Rook the F5 going after the pawn
Knight to B4 uh now you could capture on
D4 right away progress for this idea uh
the idea is that um well you will see as
it will be resolved very soon ding
captured an E5 uh here we have Rook
captures on D1 King captures and now
Knight to D3 that's the point of Knight
to B4 attacking B2 and also the at the
E5 pawn and naturally ding will give up
the E5 Pawn it's a double the E Pawn he
doesn't want to give up the B2 pawn and
allow proc to have a fast C Pawn so King
C2 we have Knight captures and E5 prog
regains material and now Knights the D2
and okay Rook D6 by Prague and if you
look at the position now uh uh could
have also captured with the Rook on E5
not with the Knight but he doesn't want
to trade Rook see uh he uh considers his
position better as he has two Pawn
Islands I think has three Pawn islands
and it's gonna be much harder for ding
to defend all of those pawns so it's uh
makes sense to leave as much attackers
as possible we have Rook to F4 biting
now comes Rook to C6 with trick King to
B1 and now Knights the D3 the Knight is
now coming to B4 where it's just going
to be a monster uh we have Rook D4
attacking the Knight Rook the C1 with
check King A2 and now Knights the B4
with check with k think the B3 and now
just King the F7 and this is the key
move in prague's Attack the Knight is
placed just spectacularly here this Rook
will attack the E3 pawn and the King
will attack the G5 Pawn once in the once
it's defended the king will attack the
H4 pawn and that that will just be too
many weaknesses for ding to defend we
have Knight to C4 now King to G6 the G
Pawn is hanging we have Pawn to H4 and
King the H5 now uh Knight the E sorry
Knight to the E5 and now Rook to E1
going after the E Pawn and there's no
good way to defend it you can't push it
because King captures on H4 so you have
to play Rook to E4 which is already a
terrible Square for the rook and not
just Rook the H1 and now pawns will
start falling and if ding tries to go
for some sort of a passive defense with
Knight to F3 uh it does really work just
Rook H3 goes after the Knight and after
Rook the F4 defending the Knight to just
Knight to D5 attacks The Rook in the
pawn and now you start losing using
material for example Rook F7 you're
going to play Knight captures on E3 and
now after Knight to G1 because you
cannot capture on G7 the Knight here is
hanging so you have to move it let's say
you attack The Rook here just Rook
captures an H4 and after will capture
Sun G7 Rook B4 check and now after King
to C3 You're Gonna Play Knight to C5
check let's say King to D3 Rook captures
an A4 the C7 Pawn is defended and of
course uh if you capture on H7 you lose
the G5 Pawn as well so not a lot to do
here for white white is down two pawns
this is completely winning for Prague so
ding tries to go for an active defense
he plays Knight to D7 okay Rook captures
on H4 uh proc starts grabbing material
Rook to E7 now and this is the best way
to to try and defend this and now Prague
just plays King captures on G5 also an
interesting attempt was just the G6 now
preparing captures uh because if you
capture on H7 and King captures uh you
you still have past the G pawn and you
can never trade Roxy frogs get rated off
then the past Pawn is just winning here
so after Rook D7 King G5 right away by
Prague Rook cat person G7 now King to H6
now you have the past H Pawn and you
have to start pushing it okay uh ding
also has the past E Pawn but for the
moment you cannot cross the E4 Square so
Rook the E7 now comes King to G5 we have
Knight to f8 and now Pawn to H5 of
course you will not allow this Pawn to
be captured Rook the G7 check King to F5
and now Rook the F7 check with King to
E4 Rook captures on C7 and King captures
an E3 now okay uh only up one Pawn but
it's the outside past H Pawn uh very
difficult to stop this we have Knights
the G6 and here proc played Rook the E4
they were both very low on time so
there's so much to calculate but I will
just show you an increase sorry Rook to
D4 was played but the correct way was
Rook the E4 and the point is what things
only counter plays to put the behind the
fast Pawn but here it's insufficient now
look at this Rook H7 King to D4
spectacular and now if the Rook is
captured Rook the E3 Checkmate the
Knight covers C2 uh in day two this is
covered by The Rook this is covered by
the king uh you you will not be able to
to grab that H5 Pawn you're gonna have
to go for some checks but look at this
now Rook D7 check King C5 Rook C7 trick
let's say King to D5 Rook D7 check King
the E6 and now after Rook to H7 you have
this amazing King to F5 now again white
cannot capture because King characters
and G6 and once the Knight moves you
play King to G5 and you defend your your
H Pawn so uh really incredible stuff
where instead of going uh after the the
pawn to defend it uh you actually go all
the way up the board and then all the
way here and then you defend it like
this chess is sometimes weird like that
but okay uh Rook the D4 was played by
Prague and this is now not as great as
it takes away the D4 Square from the
white king which is a a crucial Tempo uh
in order to
uh well just continue continue pushing
so here ding goes for Rook to H7 right
away and now Rook the D3 with check okay
probably will figure out a different way
to defend the Pawn King to C4 now Rook
to D5 he defends the pawn this way we
have rooked the E7 check King to F2 and
now Rook the B7 going after the pawn
here Rook the D6 defending and attacking
the Knight Knight to F4 attacks the H1
and now Pawn to H4 so this is also a way
to uh to push uh we have rooked the G7
uh Rook to H7 also doesn't really do all
that much um
uh for example if you play Rook to H7 uh
just the king to F3 is sufficient and
now again you will not be able to
capture the pawn if row captures King G3
and you can resign here so there's never
really a good way for ding to go after
this spawn so he tries Rook to G7 uh and
now King to F3 we have Knight the H3
this sauding sets up his defense now the
pawn cannot be pushed and the King
cannot cross the G file and now uh proc
played Knight to C6 this is move 59 uh
this is a move before the the second
time controller and of course uh uh not
enough time to calculate but I will just
show it because it's super fun Knights
the D3 is uh absolutely crushing here
point is that the B3 B2 Pawn is sagging
now let's say play King B3 look at this
Knight's the C5 check now the A4 Pawn
will be hanging as well King C4 and now
you play Rook to D4 with check King
capture Sandeep or remove the you move
the king and then uh let's say King to
B5 Rook to B4 check and then you pick up
the pawn for free as The Rook will be
guarding the H4 Pawn but if you capture
it just Knight to the E6 check and then
after the king moves you will just trade
Rooks and now of course the king and
Knight end game is completely winning
for for uh Prague but okay that's a lot
to calculate with a few seconds on the
clock Knights the C6 was played now
comes at night to G5 with the check King
F4 ding repeats Knight to H3 check ding
would be very happy with a draw here
King F3 Knights the G5 King to E3 now
Prague does not want to continue
repeating moves Knight to the H3 and now
Knights the D4 uh we have Rook to G4 now
going after the pawn but now Rook the C6
with check King to D5 and Rook the C5
with check King to D6 and now Knight to
F5 with check nicely defending the dh4
Pawn King to D7 and now King to F3
forcing The Rook away from the fourth
rank so Rook to G6 and now Rook the D5
check King to E6 and now just Knight the
E3 nicely defending the Rook Knight the
G1 with track King the E4 and now Knight
to H3 again setting up a blockade but
now Rook to D4 and now everything is
nicely defended also the A4 Pawn is
attacked uh frog just creating too many
weaknesses for them to handle B3 and now
Rook to B4 we have Rook to F6 one last
attempt at uh trying to hold the game
before capture some B3 Rook to F4 check
will pick up the past Pawn but probably
just plays King to D3 he hides his King
to safety and now you will lose one more
pawn and uh well that's just the
position no one can hold so it was in
this position and move 73 that
dinglieren resigned to the game as there
is nothing more to be done here and
absolutely uh crushing win for for black
nananda uh ding tried something
something weird in the opening he he
tried to one line no one ever played
which is considered sub-optimal but he
thought okay it gives me an equal game
there's just no way for uh for black to
get any activity in here but and while
all that is true Prague just outplayed
him so throughout the game there was no
blunder there there wasn't no a great
mistake that Ding committed it's just
that uh a move by move perhaps slightly
uh you know outplayed him and then those
0.1 0.10.1 advantages piled up and all
of a sudden his position was completely
winning so here you resign uh there's
just no good way to to continue let's
say you try to go after the H4 Pawn
let's say Rook capture some B3 Knight to
F3 goes after the pawn even just uh you
know just B5 wins the game like a
captain B5 real captors now the a pawn
is Unstoppable Knight captures on H4 or
if you don't capture then the H Pawn
also marches forward Knight captures not
Rook B6 check your trade Rooks that's it
King E5 captures captures and you
advance the pawn to Victory so uh it's
uh so winning that it you can choose
pretty much any line it would it will
still be winning
uh so yeah very nicely done by Prague uh
taking down a 2800 player in the world's
Championship Challenger uh also here are
the those are not the standings of this
tournament sorry now let me just uh
find it okay here it is
uh there we go uh standings after four
rounds uh today's the rest today so uh
tomorrow we'll be continuing with round
five uh but you have Anish giri uh
leading with three points after beating
Magnus Carlsen tied with Abdul Satur of
another back also with three points
after beating uh parhamak Sulu then with
two and a half points Fabiano caruana
and pragnananda with two points
Magnus Carlsen Wesley so ding lyron with
one and a half pointsulo Vincent kaimer
uh
forest and also uh in last place gukesh
with one point so far he had a he had a
tough start to the to the tournament but
uh you know he's a very strong player
we'll see if he will be able to
recollect himself and uh you know deal
some damage uh sure that's the game
again hope you guys enjoyed it uh I I
think it's absolutely spectacular that
both uh well the only two 2800 players
in the world in classical lost their
games in the same round in the same
tournament Magnus uh losing the game
that we've already shown ending now
losing the pregnant and uh absolutely
absolutely incredible uh so yeah very
exciting tournament uh I would like to
thank Dominic Pinterest Dominique itzeli
uh Jeffrey Manser and the Richard F
sayash for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the Tata steel until it
finishes so thank you all I will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day